next up we're beaming into the future
with today's food
okay
okay all right ross i know um
tell me all about this okay well uh hold
on to your hat all right because mash
reports there's a brand new spoon that's
supposed to make food taste better what
yeah this spoon is called the smart
spoon it's 29
and it claims its sensory technology
will excite your taste buds like they've
quote never been stimulated before
okay
so like this is a normal spoon this is
the
expensive spoon and they say it enhances
the flavor and improves the aftertaste
so do you want to try it we have mac and
cheese and and uh ice cream here let's
try first with the regular spoon oh so i
can compare okay i'm gonna go and for my
like this is you know my favorite food
on planet earth right here macaroni and
cheese okay
look good that's good now let's try it
with the um
enhancing
spoon mean it tastes the same
i mean it's not bad because i'm eating
ice cream so it's going to be good but
let's take a real bite
how dare you
can you get your lips like into the
spoon like
it's too deep it is it's too deep i
can't get my mouth in it it's like i'm
like
oh
i feel like this is a deprivate like
this is
i don't like it i don't like it either
i'm proud of them but i don't like it
i'm happy either way just give me a
vessel you know i just need my hand
[Music]